Let's say we have
two reservoirs.
Let's say up here, I have
my hot reservoir.
It's at th for hot.
And I have my engine.
It's going to be a Carnot
engine, because we'll learn
that no engine is better,
at least from an
efficiency point of view.
We have to be careful when
we say "better."
We have our Carnot engine,
and it operates on heat
differentials.
So it takes some heat from
our hot heat source.
It takes some heat there.
Let's call that q1.
And it does some work.
Work is a good thing, so I'll
make that in green.
It does some work, and then
the surplus energy, the
surplus heat, q2, then goes
to our cold reservoir.
I'll do that right there.
t cold.
Now, I made multiple
insinuations in the previous
video that this is the most
efficient engine that can be
created between two reservoirs,
th and tc.
Now, you come along and say,
no, no, no, no, no.
I know of a friend, he has
invented a new engine that is
more efficient than this engine
between these same two
reservoirs.
And you go, and you proceed to
draw this same type of diagram
for your friend's engine.
You say, look-- let me make it
clear-- this is the same
reservoir, these same reservoirs
we're dealing with.
Actually, I should probably draw
this line all the way,
because I'm going to have to
do multiple engines here.
So the same reservoir we're
dealing with, right?
This is all the hot reservoir,
th th, and this is all the
cold reservoir.
I need space for multiple
engines that we're
going to deal with.
So your friend has an engine.
We'll call it the
super engine.
And your friend's claim-- and
I'll show you why your
friend's claim cannot be true,
if you believe the second law
of thermodynamics-- so your
friend's claim, they have the
super engine.
And they claim that look, I
can actually take in q1.
I can take in that same heat
from this heat source up here.
But I can produce more work
than your Carnot engine.
I could produce 1 plus x.
I don't want to get
too algebraic.
But let's say, you produce w.
I produce w times 1
plus x of work.
Where x is a positive number.
So he's saying, look,
x is greater than 0.
Whatever that number he
might feed you is.
And then the rest of
the energy that's
left over is what?
It's q1 minus this.
So it's q1 minus w
times 1 plus x.
And just to be clear, q2 right
here, I could rewrite that as
q1 minus w.
Fair enough.
So you look at that.
You come to me with this, and
I say, no, no, no, no.
This cannot be true.
Because if this were, then we
would solve literally all of
the world's energy problems. And
I'm about to show you why
we could solve all of the
world's energy problems, and
we would have a perpetual motion
machine, and be able to
defy all sorts of things
if we had this.
Now, this is my Carnot engine.
But I could devise a reverse
Carnot engine, right?
Let me make a reverse
Carnot engine.
So my reverse Carnot engine
would look like this.
And it's going to do the same
thing, but in reverse.
So instead of producing q1 minus
w here and putting it
into tc, it could take in q1
minus w from our cold source--
so could take that in-- or even
better, let's scale it up
a little bit.
Let's say it takes in q1
minus w times 1 plus x.
So I've just made a slightly
larger reversed Carnot engine.
Now, if I take in that much--
in order to do this in
reverse, I'm going to have to
take in, I'm going to have to
scale up this Carnot engine
and reverse everything.
So instead of producing work,
I'm now going to need work to
go on the other direction, and
I've scaled it up by 1 plus x.
So I'm going to need the
amount of work here
times 1 plus x.
And then I'm going to push q1,
but I've scaled it up.
I'm going to push in
q1 times 1 plus x
into my hot heat source.
And once again, this isn't
defying the laws of
thermodynamics.
I'm taking up some work.
There's work that needs to be
done in order to do this.
But all of a sudden, you come
to me and say, look, this is
an awesome deal.
You have this nice engine
that works this way.
My friend has a super engine.
Let's just couple
them together.
Let's take the work that he
produces right here-- he
produces w times 1 plus x, and
that just happens to be the
amount of work that you need
to operate your engine.
So you just feed that
into there.
So what's the net effect
of these two engines?
So let me do another, scroll
a little bit more.
Actually, that might be
the best way to do it.
So let me make sure that we
understand that these are the
same heat sinks or heat sources
that we're using the
whole time.
So that's my hot source, my
cold source is down here.
So if I add our two engines
together-- so if I have a, you
know, let me call it a-- I'm
going to pick a new color.
These colors are getting
monotonous.
Nope.
I wanted to do the
rectangle tool.
There you go.
All right.
So I combine these two
engines together.
Essentially I just put a
big box around them.
They're both operating between
these two heat sources.
These two reservoirs.
So I call this the, you know,
your super engine plus my
reverse Carnot engine.
So what's happening now?
What's the net heat that's
being taken in
or put out of here?
So we have q1-- we have--
let me see.
We have q1 minus w 1 plus x, but
in this direction, we have
q1-- so in this direction,
we could rewrite this.
I want to make sure you're
clear on the algebra.
This could be rewritten
as what?
As q1 times 1 plus x times, or
minus, w times 1 place x.
Right?
Now, if you compare these
terms, this is the
same as this term.
This term is bigger
than this term.
Right?
This term is clearly bigger,
because we're multiplying it
by something larger than 1.
It's bigger than this storm.
So if we combine these two, the
upward movement, or the
amount of heat I'm taking up
from my reverse Carnot, is
going to be greater than the
amount of heat being put in by
your friend's super engine.
And we can actually calculate
the amount.
We can just take this amount
minus that amount, and that's
the net upward movement.
So the net upward movement
from our cold
reservoir is what?
It's this value minus
this value.
So minus q1 minus w 1 plus x.
If we take a minus, we're
going to subtract it.
So it's a minus and a plus.
These cancel out.
This minus cancels out with--
so this first term could be
rewritten as q1 plus q1x.
Right?
We could rewrite it that way.
So this cancels out with that.
And so the net upward movement
when we combine the two
engines is q1 times x.
Fair enough.
Now what about the
work transfer?
Well, whatever work this guy
produces is exactly the amount
of work that I need.
So no outside work has to
be done on the system.
It just works.
This guy produces work, this
guy uses the work.
Now what's in that
heat transferred
up to our hot reservoir?
What's the amount of heat?
Well, it's the difference
between these two.
And this is clearly a larger
number than this one, so the
upward movement dominates.
So what's this minus that?
So this can be rewritten
as q1 plus q1x, right?
I just distributed the q1.
We're going to subtract
that out.
Minus q1.
You're left with q1x.
So the net movement,
when we combine the
two engines, is q1x.
So what's happening here?
I have no external energy or
work has to be expended into
this system.
And it's just taking heat from
a cold body, and it's moving
it to a warm body.
And it does this indefinitely.
It'll do this as much
as I want to.
I can just build a bigger one.
It'll do it on even a larger
and larger scale.
So if you think about it, I
could heat my house with ice
by just making the ice colder.
I could create steam from things
that arbitrarily cold.
This goes against the second
law of thermodynamics.
The net entropy in this
world is going down.
Because what's happening here?
This is just a straight up
transfer of q1x from a cold
body to a hot body.
So what's the net change
in entropy here?
The change in entropy
of the universe.
Well, the hot body is gaining
some heat, so it's q1x over
the temperature of the hot body,
and then the cold body
is losing the same amount.
So it's minus q1x over
the cold body.
Now, this is a bigger number
than this is, right?
Because the denominator
is smaller.
This is a cold body.
Its temperature in Kelvin will
be a smaller number.
So this is going to be less than
0, which the second law
of thermodynamics tells
us cannot be.
The entropy cannot shrink
in the universe.
This whole thing is an
independent system, and the
entropy is shrinking.
And we can make the entropy
shrink arbitrarily if we just
scale up our x's enough.
So this is why the Carnot engine
is the most efficient
engine possible.
Because if anyone claimed to
have a more efficient engine,
you could couple it with a
reverse Carnot engine, and
then create this perpetual
reverse-- I guess you could
call it a perpetual
refrigeration machine that
just out of the blue creates
anti-entropy from anywhere,
and it would be this perpetual
energy source that creates
energy out of nothing.
And so this is just something
that cannot be done in our
world, especially if you believe
the second law of
thermodynamics.
So the most efficient engine
is the Carnot engine, where
its efficiency is described as 1
minus the temperature of the
cold body divided
by the hot body.
So if I have two temperature
reservoirs, let's say that my
hot one is at 500 Kelvin, and my
cold one is at 300 Kelvin,
and I have some engine that
takes heat from there, and
transfers it there, and
does some work.
The most efficient engine, if
I were to remove all the
friction in the engine, the
highest efficiency I could get
would be 1 minus 300 Kelvin over
500 Kelvin, which is 1
minus 3/5, which is 2/5, which
is equal to 0.4, which is
equal to 40%.
So if someone tells you that
they made an engine that
operates between a reservoir
that's 500 Kelvin and 300
Kelvin, and they say, oh, I've
achieved 41% percent
efficiency.
I've really polished
the thing well.
You know that they are lying.
So anyway, hopefully you found
that reasonably interesting,
and I'll see you in
the next video.